you know a good stable Family Man and
that's not the guy that you're going to
tame to make a stable man it's just not
going to happen do you guys think women
um pick nice guys or bad boys
oh I feel like um first
I will say
I think that when they're young under 25
they go for the bad bad boys okay and
then they learn from experience
I'm trying to put it the best yeah yeah
are you talking from experience no I'm
just saying
but yeah I think that's the bad boys I
agree I think bad boys
I would agree but I personally wouldn't
go for a bad boy because I learned from
other people's mistakes I was going to
say that you said you said you came from
a two-parent home right do you think
that's helped you vet guys better with
guys yeah because you have your dad as
like an example not necessarily because
I speak to my brother I have an older
brother I speak to him about like boy
problems if I ever have yeah but um I
wouldn't speak to my dad about it
because where I was I was born here and
my dad's from Ghana so they have like
traditional ideologies about what a
relationship should consist of and what
it shouldn't you know what I mean so
it's just like it's really hard to
explain that to my father now you know
what I mean so I just how long have your
parents been married
um plus 30 years you don't think it's
good to get an opinion of a guy that's
been married 30 plus years on what to
look for I just feel like I haven't had
that connection with my dad so I'd find
it a little bit awkward to have that
conversation with him whereas with me
and my brother I see my brother more as
a paternal figure because we have such a
of us um age Gap so um yeah but you know
about I think it would be good to get
advice from people who have been in
relationships for that long if they are
in tune with what is going on in 2022
and a lot and I think a lot of parents
who have been
um
together for a long time are together
because they're from a different era but
isn't it kind of impossible for that for
those two things to be together you know
it's somewhat mutually exclusive for
them to be together that long and then
also be in tune with what's going on now
because they haven't been in the data
market right now so yeah exactly it's
it's kind of like I can't be asking my
dad about advice for what's going on now
when he was dating what 40 years ago
yeah but I think there's just some
wisdom that comes from experience and
success
like I was actually shocked when I
started asking my dad for like like
dating advice a little bit like he men
are very insightful I think it's good
you talk to your brother too because I
think men just have it they're better at
vetting men than women are a lot of the
time because we can like
I don't know like the red flag deep pink
yeah men no men yeah yeah man no so you
can say something Charlie
it was about what you said about
um being in tune with today's dating
scene if you've been married for such a
long time 30 years
I don't think it makes any difference
because the trends are the same go on
See you ladies admit you'd go for a bad
boy in your early years
I think if I was to ask the Elder women
in my family when they were single
before they got married what kind of men
were they attracted to before they
settled down they'd probably say the
same thing I can see the trend happening
with uh like even girls that I've dated
they'll go with a bad weather that most
of the women that I know that have got
children that are single they're all to
Bad Boy men
and I find is that what you are I
wouldn't I wouldn't say no I wouldn't
say I'm a bad boy no I wouldn't say I'm
a bad boy sorry continue no no I know
but I would say that I've got elements
of you know being a bit direct and being
very much like this is what we need to
do to get this stuff done and I don't
mind dismissing a situation or a
relationship if it's not working out and
it's beneficial to the progress of my
family right see I don't necessarily
need a woman to walk into my situation
and think she's going to be a mum
there's a difference between what
I think single men want from
relationships versus what single mothers
want from so your mother's want to step
yeah earlier on you you want that guy to
come in and and look after you because
that would be the natural order of
things the man heads your family whether
it be the biological man to your
children or another one the extra man is
what I will call him
um you call him the extra man the extra
but he's always going to be extra
because he's like he's never going to
come first right he's not the biological
dad the kid knows that the mum knows
that but I find that men especially
myself I speak to myself I don't expect
any woman to walk into my life and say
I'm I'm expected to be a stepmom and
I'll make that very clear like I'll make
you very clear this is my responsibility
if you want to take part
and it gets to that point and you meet
my child and you want to go there you
can but it's not an expectation correct
and I think that's where you have the
jadedness that you have from men that
try to avoid single moms
because there is that expectation
whether women want to want to admit it
or not that they must step up to the
mark yeah and fill the void that the
alpha the bad boy left behind right
but I think also when it comes to men
and avoiding single moms you know I'm
24. right now I'm taking my Prime
physically in terms of my own potential
you know there's still time to go there
but
the way I I look at it is why would I
want to get um go into a family that's
already somewhat built and have to have
to fill that role when I can you know
find someone who doesn't have a kid
build my own home and again like you
were saying before you know I have
certain rights to that kid in terms of
how I discipline him how I do certain
things what he um their their routine
whereas when it's not my child fair
enough I can love that kid
but the moment a mum doesn't love me
anymore it's done it's finished you're
right so you're right and you have no
rights to the kids after so like I've
talked to
um guys that have raised a kid for like
10 years or five years and and they fall
in love with the kid and then it's over
and they can't see the kid anymore I had
to deal with that myself I had to deal
with that I had to it's a double breakup
right so you break up with the mother
and you also break up with the child and
it's like well I've raised you for this
long and now I'm not even allowed to see
like you became my child do you know
what I mean and so it's like and that's
one of the reasons why I tell men if
they do get with women who are single
mothers you need to understand exactly
what you're getting yourself into you
know do you think that the step dad
should be able to adopt the kids if
they're in the home more than the actual
dad
um
no
I would say that might depend on the
child
because of how important it is for a man
to be in the home I think that might be
the way to go
um because again you know fathers stop
children um stop signs from ending up in
prison you know if if a child is a
scammer a drug dealer or is involved in
any form of the program activity that
could land him in prison it tends to be
because the father isn't there you know
if uh if a daughter ends up you know in
any form of sex work again it tends to
be because you know the father isn't
there and so if a man is there you know
a a stepfather is there and he's and
he's he's stepping up then I I think it
makes sense for that child to have the
stability of you know be knowing I am
adopted by this man this man is
basically my father-in though what do
you guys think
a fitness potential risk if you well it
depends on the um status of the
relationship I I would personally be
married to the person
um I wouldn't take any risk because you
never know what their intentions are
you've got a young kid you never know if
they're you know rapists and stuff like
that so that's one that's one aspect of
it but I would agree with you and say
that a paternal figure in a household is
essential in terms of parenting and yeah
so I would agree
I also think that the child should have
some say at a certain age
um because if the biological father is
still stepping up to the plate in some
way shape or form then I feel like then
like if the child is old enough they
should have some kind of say because if
they're adopted or not it won't stop the
person being around and if they're of
age they can make that decision to go
and see them if they're even if they're
not adopted
um so I think it really depends
situationally
yeah I agree with both of you guys
um the marriage you know if you're
married to the person you are building
up your future with them they're you
know they've been there for the child
um I'd say five six plus years the
child's of you know of age where that
you know that they can have a say in the
process
um I do think the adoption
um would be um essential and beneficial
for for the household and an option that
should be um yeah that could that could
happen do you think the chartered the
father should be able to adopt the child
I don't it's a tough question right
because I think of things from both
sides so on one hand
um I I don't really want to see rights
taken away from the biological dad right
which is why I think it's really
important that it starts at 50 50
custody right but if it's a situation
where it's like an every other weekend
type of thing right and the stepdad's in
the house more than the actual dad I
mean it kind of makes sense because he's
going to have a bigger impact than the
actual Dad yeah but the child this is
the thing about that the child always
knows who their biological father is you
could raise a child for years right and
that child could not know their actual
biological father but they know you're
not it do you think kids that or dads
that are raising kids that aren't theirs
it's the same
dads are raising kids yeah they say um
there's some studies that say like 20 25
of men are raising a child that's not
actually theirs yeah that's very true
yeah what one in 25 Farmers
yeah one in 20. I mean it might be lower
one he says one in 25. but I'm asking in
those in those situations what do you do
you think the kids know no the kids
don't know
does the child know that this person is
not their biological father yeah because
you said like the kid knows deep down
right no I'm not it's not a deep down
thing I'm saying that the mother always
the mothers told the child at some point
in time that they've got a dad right
if a new man arrives the mother's not
going to say oh this is your dad this is
I don't know Uncle whoever or this is my
friend or whatever that child still
knows that's not their dad they know
they have one and they know that that
new person is not the not the daddy so I